let's just give you a sense of what
we're talking about here when it comes
to that market impact you know how big
was this in comparison with other crises
this shows you this line chart just
shows you the footsie 100 it's the main
benchmark index of shares in the UK and
anything going up obviously as stronger
anything going down is weaker and you
can see there was starting here in 2016
so just after the referendum you can see
the market rows and rows and rows and
rows and you've had a kind of bumpy ride
over the course of the last few years
but what happened in the last week I
haven't put that on let's add on the
last week the coronavirus impact what's
it look like you can see a very big fall
indeed and actually when you take that
line and draw it back that is the lowest
that this market has been since all the
way back here in 2016 the lowest that
the first c100 has been since the
aftermath of that EU referendum and to
put that into context what we're talking
about here with this one-week worth of
force you know how big is that in
historical context let's look back all
the way to 1984 when the market was set
up at all of the biggest falls in the
footsie 100 over that period so you've
got Black Monday 1987 famous massive
falls in the stock market that week in
late October 1987 the financial crisis
of course we can't forget the financial
crisis of 2008 but actually this this
last week was the biggest set of falls
in the footsie 100 the UK's benchmark
index that we've seen since the third
biggest that we've seen in the history
the first 100 and the biggest that we've
seen since the financial crisis and
actually bigger than the euro crisis
they're bigger than some of the other
crises some of the other weeks that we
had during the financial crises so this
is a historic level of falls that we've
seen in UK share prices and the historic
levels - of volatility when you look at
levels of volatility so what it's called
the VIX it's a measure of just how
volatile markets not just in the UK are
but around the world and just look at
this it goes to them from the start of
last year and just look at how much it
is rocket if that's actually the highest
that volatility index has been in many
many years I think it's actually higher
than it was during some periods of the
financial crisis because it's really
taken people by surprise and that impact
on the economy was one thing that Mark
Carney wanted to talk about I spoke to
him just earlier on
his response on coronavirus in isolation
we would expect that world growth would
be lower than it otherwise would be and
that has a knock-on effect on the UK
we're not picking it up yet at all in
the UK economic indicators the survey
indicators are other things but if the
world's slower than it otherwise would
be
the UK's very open economy has an impact
it's worth saying since that interview
actually j-pal who's the chairman of the
Federal Reserve so that's the u.s.
equivalent of the Bank of England their
central bank has also said it poses
risks for the US economy that's just in
the last few minutes but what does this
actually mean for you well the average
adult stocks and shares Isis so a
savings account of the the icer has over
ten thousand one hundred and twenty four
pounds now if you were invested in the
footsie 100 index and with this week's
loss of just over 11 percent you would
be short a whopping 1144 pounds so a big
fall there and that is gonna I'm afraid
effect many of our pockets